[Music]
so Oscar you asked the question what are
some of the easiest ways that you can
prove that the earth is round because
apparently this is something that we're
debating I have no idea why that's a
hard thing for me to even start talking
about because there are so many proofs
that the earth is round it's difficult
to know where to start and it's not okay
to think that the earth is flat this is
not a viable argument I have friends who
have been on the International Space
Station they have orbited the earth once
every 90 minutes you know I have had
personal experience with people that
have been up in space and can see with
their own eyes that the earth is round
and of course we've taken all of these
amazing pictures from space that they're
so beautiful all those pictures of the
earth so I don't really know what's
going on right now with this earth is
flat thing but I will tell you that this
is one of the things I really enjoyed
teaching my own astronomy class about
because there are proofs all around you
is not difficult to know that the earth
is round in fact people have known this
for way more than 2,000 years the
ancient Greeks actually had a number of
really elegant wonderful proofs that the
earth was a sphere so let's start from
the simple to the slightly more
complicated one of the things you can
see yourself with a pair of binoculars
is if you actually go out to a lake and
there are boats on that lake the farther
away a boat is the more the bottom of
the boat will disappear and you'll
basically just see the mast of the boat
and as a boat goes farther and farther
away the last thing you will see is the
very top of the mast of that boat and
that's because the boat is actually
going over the horizon that's curved and
that means that as it goes farther and
farther away you see less and less of
the bottom of it and more of the top of
that you can see that with binoculars by
an ocean by a lake it's really easy that
wouldn't happen if the earth were flat
you would simply see the boat getting
smaller and smaller and smaller as it
went farther away but you'd be able to
see the whole thing with the same
proportions now another way that you can
tell that we're on a sphere is to think
about how there's something called the
on the earth and the tropics are a
places near the equator of the earth
where sometimes the Sun is overhead in
the sky and this was actually something
that the Greeks used not only to prove
that the earth was around about 2,000
years ago but they actually measured the
circumference of the earth accurate to
within just a couple percent two
thousand years ago we've known that the
earth was round there was a really
brilliant Greek scientist called
Aristophanes and Aristophanes noticed
that there was a town called Sian and on
a certain date the Sun would actually
shine straight down to the bottom of a
well that meant the Sun was directly
overhead you could look down a well and
see the sun shining back at you and on
the very same date farther away in the
city of Alexandria that didn't happen
the Sun was not directly overhead it was
a slight angle and all the Aristophanes
did was he measured the difference in
the angle of the Sun it was straight
overhead and Syene in Alexandria it was
a little bit less than overhead and he
rationed that that change in angle from
one city to another was probably
indicative of us being on a curved
surface and you could make all kinds of
measurements even between those two
cities and see that the angles were
different the Sun was at a different
place in the sky using this he actually
measured the circumference of the earth
and he got it right
2,000 years ago so another really simple
proof is that on any given date at
different cities and different places
around the world the Sun is at different
angles in the sky that wouldn't happen
if the earth wasn't round then there are
some other proofs that are a little more
obscure but they're actually really
lovely and one is to observe what
happens during a lunar eclipse now a
lunar eclipse happens when the earth
casts a shadow on the moon the moon
actually goes dark in fact if you've
seen one you can actually see the earth
shadow go across the moon and when the
moon is entirely in the Earth's shadow
the moon looks kind of dark and even
kind of red colored it's really really
beautiful
what's happening in that case is that
the Sun is on one side of the earth
there this in the middle and it's
casting a shadow the earth is casting a
shadow on the moon and
as the shadow moves across the moon
you'll notice that the shadow is curved
it's round so something like the Sun
that's bigger than the earth and is able
to cast a shadow of the earth on the
moon can actually show you the shape of
the earth a high you might say but could
the earth be a disc could it be flat but
it's actually still shaped like a disc
not like a sphere there was a Greek
scientist called Aristarchus and what he
noticed was that you can get a lunar
eclipse at many different angles where
the Sun is sometimes the shadow goes
straight across the moon sometimes it
just kind of glances the moon just a
little bit as in shadow just on the top
or on the bottom from every different
vantage point every different angle of
the Sun is casting a shadow
you always get a perfectly curved shadow
the only shape that can cast a shadow
that's curved from any direction you put
the light is a sphere so people have
known that the earth is spherical for
thousands of years it's not okay to say
that the earth is flat this is some sort
of strange denial I don't know where it
comes from and it's something where I
keep getting this question we really
need to put this question to bed because
we've known the earth as a sphere for a
long time there there's some even
well-meaning people that have kind of
you know they say well I don't really
believe the earth is flat but I'm not
really sure at what to think about it
and they've asked me some interesting
questions like you know they've heard
that the that space is very hot you know
that when you when you go up above the
atmosphere the temperature space is
millions of degrees which is true the
the problem is there's basically no air
at all so I mean I mean the the gas
right around the earth is actually
millions of degrees hot that's actually
true but there's almost none of it it's
almost nothing like one single proton
whizzes by you and a temperature of a
million degrees it's not the same as
temperature like in the air it's not the
same thing at all so that one was one
that I get sometimes and the other one
is actually said this to somebody I
couldn't believe they'd never thought of
it that you know with binoculars you can
see planets you can see Saturn and
Jupiter you couldn't as you can see Mars
with a telescope the Sun the moon
everything else you see in the solar
system is a sphere so we're the one
thing that is different
you know and that actually that actually
made somebody who was who was more
interested in actually hearing
information that she got them to think
they're like you're right you know you
know everything else we take a picture
of as a sphere
[Music]